[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed it is now
time for our radio rx 5700 XT and rx
5700 review don't worry I only got the
5700 here I have tested the 5700 XT but
it's now been shipped off to Tim for his
anti-lag testing and all the other
things he wants to do so yeah I've only
got this guy on hand for this this
portion of the filming but I've
obviously got b-roll of the 5700 XT and
also don't worry there's plenty more
rise and content on the way I've now
purchased the horizon 530 600 so the
review on this guy is coming soon it's
got a little cooler so that's why the
box is smaller and a plenty more Rison
goodness to come before that though
today's video is sponsored by Corsair
and their void Pro RGB and HS 70
wireless gaming headsets both offer an
exceptional audio experience using
specially tuned 50 millimeter neodymium
speaker drivers and the premium build
quality means they're not just highly
durable but also very comfortable both
offer a 16 hour runtime with a slew of
other features so for more information
please check them out via the link in
the video description so let's quickly
go over some specs and then we'll jump
right into the benchmarks as you
probably know these new Navi GPUs are
built using TSMC 7 nanometre
manufacturing process and because of
this they are significantly smaller than
the previous Radeon rx Vega 56 and 64
parts when compared to Vega 10 Navi
packs 18% fewer transistors but it's
almost 50% smaller at just 251
millimeters squared whereas Vega 64
featured 64 compute units and Vega 56 56
compute units the RX 5700 gets 36 units
and the 5700 XT gets 40 however this is
somewhat of a meaningless comparison as
the cause featured in the Navi GPUs are
quite a bit different to those in the
Vega based GPUs the peak single
precision performance of the 5700 XT is
down 23% on Vega 64 but the pixel fill
rate has been increased by 23% and
that's what make the 5700 XT a better
gaming GPU aim DS also done away with
HBM for these parts and instead they're
using 8 gigabytes of gddr5
memory for bandwidth the 448 gigabytes
per second using a 256 bit wide memory
bus so the same peak memory bandwidth as
the new 2060 super and 2070 super
initially the 5700 XT was set to cost
450 dollars u.s. but last minute
AMD revealed a surprising price cut
that's all the 5,700 XT dropped by $50
making it a $400 part
meanwhile the 5700 was reduced by $30
taking it from $380 us down to 350
dollars u.s. so the price cut was
unexpected but it is very exciting as it
should make these parts are very very
competitive in terms of cost per frame
AMD is claiming a 225 watt board power
rating for the 5700 XT and 185 watts for
the 5,700 and these ratings are quite a
bit lower than the equivalent Vega 10
parts as for clock speeds they can be a
little misleading though at least aim D
has specified the gaming clock the boost
clock is virtually meaningless as this
frequency isn't achieved beyond the
first few seconds of gaming thankfully
though the gaming clock is accurate and
we generally saw clock speeds around 50
megahertz higher than what AMD were
claiming but then we are only testing in
a 21 degree environment so that could
change for those of you in hotter rooms
though we suspect the fan speed will
just ramp up to maintain those clock
speeds oh and just lastly they do
support PCIe 4.0 which is nice and all
that but for these particular GPUs in
today's games it offers no performance
improvements over 3.0 anyway that's
enough looking at the specs let's just
get on with it
so quickly we'll just go over the test
system specs and then of course jump
into the blue bar graphs for testing
I've used the Intel Core I 999 hiroko
clocked at 5 gigahertz with 32 gigabytes
of ddr4 3400 memory the latest drivers
available at the time I testing have
been used and all this data is fresh
brand-new for this video and collected
in the past two weeks we have 12 games
to look at before the usual performance
breakdowns and cost per frame data I'll
be focusing on 1440p performance but for
all the 1080p and 4k results please head
over to our patreon page the links in
the video description you better get
them all there for free ok let's
get into the results first up we have
battlefield 5 and right away we have
some strange-looking results the new
Radeon rx 5700 XT is extremely
impressive rendering 112 FPS an average
but what's strange here is the unusually
low 1% low performance whereas the 5700
XT is 11% faster and the RT X 2070 super
for the average framerate it was just
one percent faster for the 1% lower
result I'm not really sure if this is an
issue that AMD will be able to address
with a future driver but at least I can
confirm the gameplay was still very
smooth with no noticeable stuttering we
see the same thing with this standard
5700 as well although it was able to
match the average framerate of the 2070
super the 1% low result was well below
that of the 2060 super again overall
performance was good but I'm just not
quite sure what's going on here I
suspect this is a driver issue as we
never saw these unexplainably low 1% low
results in any other game tested frame
rates in Rainbow six siege for example
were very consistent that said though
the RX 5700 XT did fall well short of
the 2070 super still it did deliver rx
2070 light performance and was just 5
percent slower than the Radeon 7 the
5700 on the other hand well I think that
was a bit more impressive it fell just
9% behind the 2060 super though I am
hoping we see more favorable results for
AMD in the other games tested
unfortunately that's not the case with
Metro Exodus here the margins are quite
similar to what we just saw here the
5700 x2 trailed the 2070 Super by an 11%
margin very this time the 5700 was just
6% slower than the 2060 super the Radeon
7 was also 17% fast and the 5700 XT
though of course it is a much more
expensive product moving on to Resident
Evil 2 and we see fairly competitive
results here the 5700 XT was just 5%
slower than 2070 super while the 5,700
was 4% slower than the 2060 Super so
although Nvidia does enjoy a performance
advantage in this title their competing
products also cost more so it'll be
interesting to see how they can pay in a
cost per frame analysis at the end of
the video next up we
shut off the Tomb Raider and here the
5700 and 2600 super a neck-and-neck just
a frame in it here which is within the
margin of error
the 5700 XT didn't do too poorly but it
was 7% slower than the 2070 super but it
also cost 10% less so we're probably
looking at a break-even scenario here
both of the new rx 5700 graphics cards
were able to deliver highly playable
performance in fortnight at 1440p using
the maximum image quality settings but
as I've said in the past it isn't a good
title for AMD when comparing performance
with the GeForce competition the 5700 XT
only managed to match the 2060 super
which obviously isn't a great result
overall moving on we find a much
stronger result for AMD in the division
2 granted they don't exactly brush aside
the GeForce competition but even so the
5700 match the 2060 super while the 5700
XT was just seven percent slower than
the 27 he's super so not a bad result
overall here we see a really good result
for the new rDNA GPUs the 5,700 just
edged out the 2060 super though really
this one is a tie and the same is true
when comparing the 5700 XT and 2070
super still this is a highly competitive
result for the new AMD GPUs I'm betting
AMD wish every title was as kind to them
as Forza horizon for because what a
shellacking we have here the standard
5700 easily beats the 2070 super leaving
the 2060 super behind in a completely
different performance tier
meanwhile the 5700 XT managed to be even
the radio and seven spitting out an
incredible 131 fps an average basically
placing it on par with the Arctic's 20i
DTI although not nearly as amazing the
far cry new dawn results are still
favorable for AMD as both 5700 GPUs
edged out or the very least matched the
GeForce competition given their both
cost a bit less this is a very solid
result for AMD another stellar result
for AMD can be seen when testing with
World War Z here the 50 750 700 XT
easily beat their nearest competitors
the 5700 XT even beat the RT X 20
the sound of 5700 was 13 percent faster
than 20 60 super though it did only
manage to just edged out Vega 56 the
last game tested is Assassin's Creed
Odyssey and here the 5700 XT was just 7%
slower than the 2070 super while the
5,700 was 13% slower than the 2060 super
so not a great result but not too
disappointing to end on either so with
all the FPS performance now in the bag
for a dozen games let's move on to check
out power consumption here we're looking
at just GPU power consumption so not the
entire graphics card not bored
consumption just the power consumed by
the GPU interestingly the 5700 XT
consume 6 percent less power than the RT
X 2070 super and 25% less than the
Radeon 7 the standard 5700 consume 27%
less power than the XT model and that
meant it was much more efficient than
even the RT X 2060 so a tremendous
result for the base model rx 5700 now
we're looking at total system
consumption we do see a few changes
now the 5700 XT consumes slightly more
power than the 2070 super which is
interesting it's not a big change but
whereas it consumes 6 percent less power
in the GPU only test now when measuring
the entire board plus the system it
consumed 2 and a half percent more power
and then we see the 5700 is now matching
the standard 2060 whereas previously it
did consume noticeably less power before
wrapping up the testing let's have a
quick look at these stock and overclock
temperatures along with the clock speeds
and fan speeds out of the box the 5700
XT ran at 84 degrees and maintained a
core clock speed of 740 megahertz and a
memory speed of 872 megahertz which is
basically 14 gigabits per second the
blower fan typically spun at 2100 rpm
and here it wasn't too loud now moving
on to overclocking for the 5700 XT we
saw a peak core clock speed of 1940
megahertz but at times it would still
drop as low as 1720 megahertz and on
average we saw a speed of about eighteen
hundred and sixty megahertz which is
about a 10 percent overclock the massive
fluctuation was due to an almost
90-degree operating temperature and
degrees the GPU tends to throttle and
with the fan running at 43% 2100 rpm
there was the potential to improve
cooling performance as for the memory I
was only able to get the GDD r6 memory
up to a transfer speed of fourteen point
three gigabits per second so that was a
bit disappointing with the core clock
speed jumping all over the place I
decided to crank up the fan to 100%
where it's incredibly noisy as it spun
at 4600 rpm but the benefit of doing
this is it drops the GPU temperature to
just 70 degrees and now the 5700 XT was
able to maintain a core clock speed of
over 2 gigahertz at all times so that's
about a 20% overclock from stock so I
reckon liquid cooling is gonna be a
pretty popular option for these 5700 XT
graphics cards as for the standard 5700
out of the box around 75 degrees with a
fan speed of 1900 rpm and it maintained
a typical operating frequency of 1670
megahertz then when overclocked with an
auto fan speed and hit 85 degrees but
the fans were only spinning at 1600 rpm
and apparently this is a bug with the
reviewer driver that will be addressed
with the public driver that you'll now
have access to that being the case for
one last test I cranked up the fan speed
to 50% manually which saw the blower fan
spin at 2700 rpm and this was quite loud
nothing crazy or unbearable but
certainly noticeable but it did allow
the 57-hundred to average a core
frequency of 1780 megahertz at just 70
degrees unfortunately I wasn't able to
push the core any higher as there
appears to be some sort of frequency cap
and I'm not sure if AMD will remove this
or if it's something that we have to
deal with ok so there's all the
performance information it was certainly
very back and forth so I'm keen to see
how they stacked up over the dozen games
tested and then of course we have a few
performance breakdown charts and then
we'll get to the cost per frame data so
let's go do all that first up we have
the battle between the 5700 and its main
competitor the r-tx 2060 super from our
12 game sample the 5,700 was on average
1% faster and a massive win in Forza
horizon 4 really helped the radeon GPU
pull off that win that said if we remove
the Forza result which some will claim
as an outlier the 5,700 is just 2%
slower and
either way it's close enough to call a
tie and I generally do this when
discussing margins that are less than 5%
we also saw highly competitive
performance in dirt rally to farcry new
dawn the division to shut off the Tomb
Raider and even Resident Evil 2 so it'll
be interesting to see how these two
stack up when it comes to the cost per
frame comparison when compared to the
r-tx 2070 the 5700 was just 2% slower on
average again it did enjoy a massive win
in Forza horizon for but even so it
pulled off solid wins in World War Z and
battlefield 5 as well then when compared
to vague 56 the 5,700 was 11% faster an
average not a massive performance uplift
after two years but the 5700 is
significantly less complex so AMD should
be able to turn a profit on this one
even at 350 dollars so there's that next
up we have the 5700 XT and it also does
well in its battle with the RT X 2070
super here it was just 2 percent slower
on average and even if we remove the
Forza result it's still just 4 percent
slower so again within that 5 percent
margin that I usually declare at I the
5700 XT was also just 9% slower than the
much more expensive RT x 2080 so you can
see why Nvidia feels the need to
introduce the 2080 super at times the
radeon GPU was up to 20 to 24 percent
slower but that still makes the 5700 xt
a much better value option as you'll see
in a moment
speaking of value the 5700 XT like the
27 is super not only eliminates the
standard 2080 but it also waves goodbye
to the compute heavy Radeon seven here
we see it's just 6% slower so I hope you
didn't just recently drop around $700 us
on a Radeon 7 for gaming alright so time
to check out just how much value these
new Radeon graphics cards offer at the
suggested prices here we have an MSRP
comparison that compares launch prices
and compared to Vega 56 is $400 u.s.
MSRP the 5700 XT offers a massive 21
percent discount per frame while the
standard 5,700 provides a 22 percent
discount so that's nice it's also a
massive improvement over the Radeon 7
and we only got that five months ago and
six dollars 54 per frame and we save the
5700 XT saves you almost 40% as you're
basically getting the same performance
for $300 off but I won't pretend like
the Radeon seven or r-tx 2080 were ever
particularly good value so let's just
move on to a comparison with the current
market prices even here at the 50 750
700 XT look very nice at their MSRP s
incredibly both are more cost-effective
than the 20 60 super and standard 20 60
as well as a gtx 1660 TI the 5700 comes
in at a rather large 14% discount per
frame when compared to the 20 60 super
and the 5700 XT well that's 18% cheaper
per frame when compared to the 20 70
super so that actually looks really good
for these new radio and GPUs in fact
even before the last minute price cut
AMD had beaten Nvidia in terms of cost
per frame and I suppose they knew it but
despite that they cut prices further
okay so time to wrap this review up last
week I wasn't super excited regarding
Nvidia's refresh the 2060 super it just
kind of slotted into the existing
pricing structure that was set a year
ago the 2070 super on the other hand
that was decent it was a nice little
upgrade at the $500 price point of
course the entire point of those new
GPUs was to disrupt AMD's narvi release
and while it certainly did put a damper
on this review initially aimed ease late
move to adjust pricing once again has
sparked a lot of excitement around the
50 750 700 xt in terms of performance
the RX 5700 looks to deliver 2060 super
light performance which is RTX 20 70
like performance and that makes it
slightly faster than vega 64 so priced
at $350 u.s. it's an exceptionally good
value option then we have the rx 5700 XT
which finds itself in a bit of a sweet
spot at $400 us coming out at a cost of
just $4.00 per frame in our tests making
it better value than the cheaper
products such as the original 2060 and
its 1660 Ti not to mention you're
getting 2070 super light performance at
a rather hefty discount so this all
means if aimed
able to stock shelves with $400 5700 XTS
and 350 dollar 5700 s then they will
have by far the best offerings at these
price points in fact for anyone spending
$700 or less the 5700 XT is now the new
go-to option at least until the 2080
super arrives later this month at that
point the 5700 XT may only be the go-to
option when spending $500 or less the
success of these new Navi GPUs really
depends on pricing and availability but
so far things are looking good for AMD
I've also been told that custom AIB
models are on the way and if they can
boost out-of-the-box performance even a
little bit while bringing about the
typical AIB card advantages then Nvidia
might be forced into making a few
pricing adjustments of their own at that
point we'll have a good old-fashioned
GPU pricing war on our hands I kept
telling you guys as soon as AMD becomes
even remotely competitive in the
mid-range to high-end market it's on and
right now it's looking very much to be
on I'm keen to see how Nvidia responds
AIB models aside the good news here
being that these cards are relatively
quiet and nothing like the Radeon seven
the fans on the 5700 XT spun at only
2100 rpm after an hour-long stress test
while the GPU was sitting at a little
over 80 degrees that's perfectly fine
it's a blower style cooler so it's not
exactly ideal but it's certainly usable
and it won't require any earmuffs again
I'm looking at you Radeon 7 in summary I
have to say I am a bit blown away by
what AMD is offering at these price
points and I'm very surprised they're as
competitive as they are I wasn't nearly
as impressed with the original pricing
despite the fact that it's still
positioned of the 5700 series ahead of
end videos super products in terms of
value barely just ahead but like I said
I wasn't that impressed with super so
just beating in video in terms of value
it would have been a lot less exciting I
just hope a few weeks from now stock
levels are good and pricing is very
close to the MSRP based on what we've
seen in the past from AMD it seems like
a long shot but let's remain positive
and yeah hope that happens
anyway no matter what I say it's really
go to impact what does happen it'll be
really nice to get these cards at MSRP
prices finally we have the Radeon
anti-lag and Radeon image sharpening
testing Tim will be covering all those
that's why they weren't featured in this
video he'll have his own detailed
analysis on the channel soon so yeah
keep an eye out for that and that is
gonna do it for this one I hope you
enjoyed this review after the rise in
review if you haven't watched the riser
if you go back and watch that but anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this it's been a
crazy crazy week here at harbor unboxed
and I think it's fair to say that's been
the case for all other media the tech
meteor anyway but yeah we're getting
towards the end of it now but like I
said I've still gotta get a review up of
that so hopefully I'll be able to do
that by tomorrow we'll see how we go
anyway if I don't wrap this one up I'm
not gonna get any more work done so that
is gonna dump this one I hope you guys
enjoy the video like button remember
that to there subscribe you can also do
that and if you appreciate the work we
do at our box then consider supporting
us on patreon thank you for watching I'm
your host Steve see you again next time
maybe tomorrow for a review of this hmm
yeah don't know miss that so subscribe
and also please like like give us some
like love give us some love some like
love I don't know I'm tired
oops probably should have done that I'm
gonna be roll that box still sorry mate
[Music]